oh I'm paired up against Derby
I think he's going to be hit with one H
for his name
okay let's try and get a Swindle in the
last round
you know
one time for the boys
so we get a part of
obviously now G6 can be met by H5
she doesn't care he just plays normal
chess
but now H4 is simply a useful move
let's go rookie one
A3
oh this is just a good attacking move
like I've been getting
I've been getting my best positions
today with 1h4
it's no doubt about that
it's really inviting me to play D5
not sure it gives anything now
should we go Queen D3
why not
I mean for Bishop B1
I can also do this later
I don't understand 86.
oh he's meeting Bishop Ford Bishop D6
that's his point
okay now I understand
yeah this is a good plan this is
actually a very good plan
hmm
yeah and I was in turning 97 so I kind
of have to act quickly
that's why I'm going Knight E4
it takes
I take
that if Knight A5 well
that I didn't see
and I have to go GF probably
C3 Maybe
Rook d8
I don't like that move what is he doing
he's just inviting Bishop C3 I could
also go D5 immediately but
I feel like this
yeah but now I can take and go D5 and
then
probably a bit better
also taking rookie 4 is not impossible
Ricky for actually
okay D5 it's gonna go E5 I believe
if it takes Bishop D5 I'm just clearly
better with the two Bishops
the E5 rookie one
but now we got F4 I think
Knight C5 and I think I'm super happy to
take the exchange
I mean these Bishops are super strong as
well as this Pawn power
I think I'm just much better
Rook C8 yeah he's trying to
this moves a little bit more annoying
than I thought
hmm
where is that the bishop C4 you can
still
suck
so I have to go F4 and suck fish by
three king of two
how to go there so there's no this which
he would have had in case of King G2
I should still be doing well here though
let's move
feels just a tad slow to me
B5 now go D6
I feel like it's losing the thread a
little bit
so first of all I got Bishop A5
I also got a E6 Bishop D6 maybe that's
not so clear
so I think I'll do this
yeah Bishop B2 I would just
take but also here yeah I should just be
winning
I'll go H5
try and just
free up some passports
yeah I guess this is a decent try it but
it
shouldn't
shouldn't help it much
these pawns are just too strong and my
Bishop is also
Bishop is also good
yeah I had to do this but this is pretty
hopeless
just take
seven
one
two three take B5 next
pretty
easy
no we're just
uh wait a sec key for I'm allowing King
G6 so I should not do that
let's go here and now
he just has no squares for his pieces
B6 I'm covering this one
and that's the end of the game
okay I think I finished with a decent or
at least half decent game
I'm not unhappy with this one
see you playing till mate
maybe is
it's fine by me
King C5
I would guess made in five
that's already thereabouts
he has H5 which delays it a little bit
but that's okay
yeah I believe that last game was all
right